I'm fueling up for a day full of organising
I promise the kids that I have their homeschool room organised and put together
by the time they got home from their vacation
and since I have no idea when they're gonna get home tomorrow
I gotta get most of it done today
I've been staring at this room for two weeks now
hoping it would magically get done
since I don't have a fairy godmother
I guess I have to do it
I ordered a bunch of different bins on Amazon for our manipulatives
really like the ones with lids
but I'm not quite sure about the colored ones
but we're gonna give it a go
they're a lot smaller than they looked in the picture
and they don't fit right in the shelf that I had originally planned
but it's fine because so far they're working really great for our art supply
I spent most of my day going through a box of books and organising our bookshelf
one side of the room is fun books for the kids to read
and the other side is history
science and reference book
I originally wanted a shelf of science and a shelf of history
the shelves are different heights and don't fit the books the right way
so it end up just being a side of non fiction book
even though I'm gonna give it my best effort
we know it's not gonna stay that way cause the moment the kids get in the books
they're gonna be all disheveled anyway
I'm gonna do my best to get over my OCD waste
cause I really want this room to be a space that they love and enjoy
and come to often the end of the day
I just really want them to love learning
and love that we get to do it together as a family